endless hypocrisy from the democrats who
can't stop breaking their own pandemic
rules while demanding everybody else
follow him stacey abrams causing a huge
uproar over this photo in a room full of
young masked children and after she got
caught abrams deleted the tweet and then
used black history month to deflect from
the criticism and the dishonesty doesn't
end there squad member jamal bowman and
new york city mayor eric adams both
caught maskless after telling everybody
to follow the rules and doubling down on
mass mandates for schools
but new jersey governor phil murphy
offering his party a breath of fresh air
announcing his state will finally end
its school mass mandate in a return to
normalcy
and other states like delaware and
connecticut are following suit but the
white house is remaining defiant
our advice to every school district is
to abide by public health guidelines it
continues to be at this point that the
cdc is advising that masks can delay
reduce transmission there are also a
number of other mitigation measures that
we've put in place but that continues to
be cdc guidance we certainly understand
and have seen in polling that the public
is tired of covid we understand that so
are we our responsibility as the federal
government is to rely on the data and
the science uh that is uh being analyzed
by our public health experts and we'll
continue to rely on that for what
recommendations we're making
and liberal comic bill maher once again
blasting his party on this issue
doesn't it make more sense to focus on
helping the vulnerable stay safe and let
the rest of us go back to living normal
lives
there's always going to be another
variant it's time to deal with a growing
list of countries have done and
announced we're going back to something
more like normal beginning with
recognizing that what we're doing to
kids is unnecessary and horrible
greg when i saw the stacey abrams
picture
i thought to myself i can't wait till
monday around five o'clock
you know what forgive me but i think i'm
going to pounce
yeah i think we're going to pounce
i'm like a like a snake
pouncing though implies a surprise
attack
when something like this happens the
media always says ah here they come fox
news is going to pounce republicans are
going to
pounce they cover that angle instead of
addressing the meaning of the story
which is the an abuse of power which is
it's crystallized in this photo uh she's
not following the rules that she
enforces on others and uh and then so
what the media would rather do because
it's so obvious is that they
look at those republicans those right
wingers but she did she actually used
black history month she she basically
said i think she said something like
it's shameful our opponents are using
black history month reading event as
impetus for false political attack
no one mentioned that except for her
so she won't wear a mask but she's happy
using race as a shield
thank you very much it's key however to
keep exp i know these these are like
small little gotcha moments they seem
small but they're not no they're not
they're not because if we let this slide
it it gets worse because the public has
to remind the leaders that we are
watching you that you are not immune
because if you're going to do this to us
we're going to do this to you it's
really important it's not small ball
because an image dana that goes out
throughout the whole country that image
is so powerful her sitting there with
the kids behind her messed up that will
change people's opinions on masks in
schools like you will not believe you
know there wasn't even an image of mitt
romney's dog on top of the car except in
your own mind mental image and that was
that was you know like no one could ever
get out of their mind this was my
favorite story from the weekend by far
um this is a person who's supposed to
have incredible political instincts and
instead of just being able to say whoops
sorry they doubled down triple down and
then they make it so much worse for
themselves they could have had a minor
inconvenience and now this is a story
that everyone will run with and it
happens to be on the same day that all
these other democratic governors are
saying you know what i think we're done
here so who should be mad right is it
the right that's mad no we're kind of
laughing saying oh okay fine
the people who are the progressive left
they should be mad because it's making
their argument so much harder to make
and also these parents have they follow
the science
the cdc is behind where everybody else
is and we know that because we've even
seen that remember the
school uh the union saying no we want
these masks and so then the white house
backfilled it to make sure that it could
happen um she this is not the first time
that she's made mistakes like this if
you think back to the remember um major
league baseball pulling out of georgia
and then she writes this piece
in the usa today and then when there was
backlash she ghost edited it
and then there was another controversy
because no the the editors let her do it
yeah this is a person who claims she is
still the governor of georgia she was
the rightful owner and you think about
the kind of press that somebody else
gets for claiming that they won an
election that they didn't win and then
they let this woman off all the time i'm
for one am very much looking forward to
the fact that camp and purdue down in
georgia will be united at least on one
issue and it will be this one that is
true judge you know the amazing part of
it is that that that she says she's
still the governor that she should have
been the governor that she actually won
the election and i say to myself she
should have been the governor you know
why because that's exactly how a
governor would be acting you'd be
sitting there with all the kids masked
but you're not masked i'll tell you what
this photo is what infuriates americans
it isn't even about the mask it's about
a a dug-in belief
that and it's not just you know mass for
thee and not for me but a reminder of
everything that we went through for two
years from businesses that had to close
economy was shut down from funerals we
couldn't go to from sick people being
sent to uh of the senior
homes all of that reminder this is a
reminder that these people see us as
nothing more than peons that they are
the exalted they can they believe go
around without a mass they don't think
they need a mess they think just the
little people need a mask and it's
infuriating when she reverts to black
history month i hate that that's
basically saying you can't criticize me
it's black history month we can
criticize anyone in this country this is
still america as hard as they try to
change it
harold ford jr
so
look i agree with dana's point that if i
were working for stacey abrams i'd have
just come out to say hey uh she's
vaccinated she's boosted she had a quick
picture she took the mask down uh you
know i'm not one to racialize things and
there was no need if there was an effort
here i don't see what what gain you made
from it but i look at the positiveness
not just her but where we are to use to
your point murphy now saying we're going
to relax the the the mass wearings
more than four out of five americans
have one vaccine more than three out of
five americans are fully vaxxed
two out of five americans are boosted
whom are eligible if we were having this
conversation a year ago and she went out
the mask it would be a far bigger story
in my mind what i do think that some of
my friends need to do and if i were
advising ms abrams so it was a mistake
and here we are have made a lot of
progress i hope we can reduce the mass
uh
mandates or the mass relax some of these
requirements but i decided to go without
uh and i don't i hope i don't i hope i
didn't get it i hope i didn't affect any
kids but to use the black history month
i look it's a little it's not my cup of
tea and not how i would have handled it
all right well she ended the pandemic
all right it's official right we didn't
have to wait for michelle king to run
naked through times square she should
have just gone with it and said you know
what nobody needs to wear a mask and
then she would have been the leader yeah
she said you know she should have said
gutfeld said it was over on the first
she is the governor that's a leadership
move yeah yeah exactly
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else